欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课。
第一小节我们来讲一下关于搜索排名机制的原则,它到底是什么样的呢?
它一共有三个原则,那么我们来记住一句话,只有符合平台规则的店铺和产品,
才有更多的机会获得曝光,否则就是盲人摸像,也就是我们所做的店铺还有产品都要符合平台规则,
否则我们就很难获得流量
我们一定要去顺风而行
根据平台的规则
根据平台的方向
去操作店铺
才能够获得更多更大的流量
第一个就是平台是以买家导向的也就是平台是非常注重买家的体验的
如果你平台里面有非常多的假信息
或者平台里面有非常多重复的产品
一搜一个关键词
A关键词就会出现
千千万万一模一样的产品
这就是直接影响了买家的体验
所以说就会导致他的信息混乱
这样体验就很差
所以说搜索主要就是以买家搜索为主
符合买家需求的信息商品
才能够更有利于获得曝光的机会
所以供应商的各项店铺信息和产品信息
越匹配买家的搜索需求
就能够有更大的展现机会
引来更多的买家
也就是我们的产品信息和客户收的这个词 相关度大，或者是说满足客户的需求 那么我们更容易获得买家的点击
第二个就是严惩作弊 作弊行为会极大的伤害到买家的体验 破坏市场公平竞争的秩序和环境
涉及到作弊行为的供应商必将受到平台的严惩 所以说我们一定一定不要去做违规或者是违反平台规则的事情
比如说我们网站发了一些尽限售侵权等这些产品
要么被扣分
要么被关店
要么被降权
那么你的流量绝对是下降
甚至是没有流量的
所以说一定要注重这些信息
不要去做这些跟平台规则相背的事情
第三个就是模糊匹配
系统搜索匹配是根据模糊匹配的逻辑进行匹配的
标题和关键词都要包含买家搜索词
才有机会被搜索匹配到。产品的综合信息越好，数据越好，那么它的排名就会越靠前。搜索词呢，它是不分大小写，单部数，同意词不分前后顺序的都可以匹配得到。这个怎么理解呢，比如说单词A是一个产品词，那么客户收A B A单词跟B单词组合的一个
A B 这个词也有可能匹配到A这款产品 听见吧 也就是它是一个包含的关系 或者是说单副数 大小鞋或者是BA这样去组合的词去搜索
这个就是不分前后顺序都能够收到你这个产品 这些就是平台的一个模糊匹配 它的原则就是这些 你一定要按照这些原则去做
当然这些第1个第2个都是非常容易做到的
第3个我们理解的这个概念是有利于我们后期去做标题去做推广
更加有利于我们去理解和调整
那么这节课我们就先讲到这里 下节课我们再见